hey guys so it's teen choice awards
today and francesca's here she just did
my hair and my makeup well the hair is
obviously not done yet francesca how are
you i'm good how are you guys good good
to see you all
doesn't she look beautiful show them
your dress oh yes my dress diana was
here yesterday and this is the one that
you guys picked out for me today so did
they get to pick well there was like
over 5000 comments this morning so i was
just trying to go through and figure out
which one they like
i'm also very excited because
my goal of the red carpet today i'm
going to be hosting with entertainment
tonight again so you guys can watch
tomorrow i need to find chris pratt and
i need to get a picture of him holding
emmett and me holding my little lego
look at this
that's me
there's
do i want to bring an emmet with a piece
of the resistance or no piece of the
resistance
oh hey chris
good look at the
teen tries awards here's your surfboard
you win
let's go to teen choice away okay guys
so we're here at the red carpet it's
actually a blue carpet so i'm gonna walk
you quickly through some of the presses
starting to show up we have all of our
photographers here probably one of my
favorite parts is they have an instagram
zero gravity wall so check this out i
just took a picture
and i'm
kind of flipped upside down but here it
is
so guys how exciting is this
so crazy megan your hair looks awesome
i love it it's so pretty sorry
okay guys we're gonna go to the carpet i
have to find a ticket and hopefully i
will see you guys in there
yeah
yeah tell them
let's try both to make it look like
so
don't you know
hey guys
right now
thank you thank you thank you thank you
to team internet this is like
making videos
like anybody can do this please just
start we love you
i can't even believe that i was
nominated for those amazing women but um
i'm so nervous thank you all so much for
voting
teen choice awards um this is us
really far away from the party
look there's the party
yeah we're gonna go get dinner now
i believe
looks like there's somebody throwing a
child over there you see that okay they
put them down well either way i had a
really fun time and
yeah i'm not sure what's going to happen
after this vlog maybe nothing
maybe something
who knows oh my god i don't know
maybe a nap